[Music]
the newest version of the Grinch is
cleaning up at the box office it raked
in 66 million dollars its first weekend
that makes it the biggest opening for
any Christmas movie ever breaking the
record set by the live-action version of
the story 18 years ago starring Jim
Carrey and that film was of course a
remake of the 1966 TV special How the
Grinch Stole Christmas so at this point
you're probably wondering did we really
need another Grinch movie we're here to
break down all the biggest differences
between the three versions and tell you
which one is the best let's start with
what we can see the character design of
the newest Grinch is pretty novel even
besides the fact that he's 3d animated
take a look at the original Grinch the
one practically ripped from the pages of
the dr. Seuss book he had a sinister
look to him with a wrinkly Cheshire Cat
like sneer Jim Carrey's Grinch was even
creepier as heavy makeup and prosthetics
gave him a snout nose in an overall
wolfish look in contrasts our new Grinch
is almost cute you can see each
individual animated hair on his body
giving him a furry looking texture that
fuzziness combined with his full round
cheeks and pear-shaped body turn this
Grinch into a surprisingly cuddly
creature looking at them next to each
other you can really see how
illumination the animation studio behind
this newest version gave Grinch a look
that's in line with some of their other
projects like the Lorax and Despicable
Me next let's take a look at the man
himself his inner workings and
motivations in the original picture book
an animated film
Zeus didn't give any reason for grinches
hatred of the holidays beyond the fact
that his heart was two sizes too small
that's not a ton of character
development the live-action movie did
provide a window into the past showing a
young Grinch being bullied by his
classmates but in that version he also
exhibited heartless tendencies from the
start even when he was just a baby
this year's origin story makes it clear
that the Grinch started out wide-eyed
and hopeful like any other kid
but growing up in an orphanage where he
spent the holidays alone year after year
slowly eroded his confidence and
compassion feeling alienated from the
cheery whois of Whoville he became a
recluse who just wants to hang out with
his dog and avoid the holidays
altogether and you really can't blame
him
the Grinch's pass is taken far more
seriously here than in the Jim Carrey
film and we can easily see why he's so
embittered now let's look at some other
characters Cindy Lou who gets some added
depth in the newest remake in both the
previous films Cindy Lou comes from a
two-parent home in the live-action
version her parents get caught up in the
materialism of the holiday season which
bothers her in this version Cindy Lou
isn't motivated by materialism but by
concern for her overworked single mom
Donna who's voiced by rashida Jones
co-director Y ro Cheney told Insider
about the decision to make Donna a
single parent saying we didn't want that
place and needs people to see him just
saccharine a postcard version of a happy
Christmas town we wanted it to feel like
a real place with real people with real
problems ok time to talk about the music
it's something that you may not
automatically think about but that
played a big role in all three movies
the soundtrack to the new film spans
several genres futuring songs by the
Jackson 5 Run DMC and the hip hop
boyband Brock Hampton meanwhile rapper
Tyler the Creator put his own catchy
take on the original theme song
[Music]
Tyler also released a boisterous EP of
holiday music for the Grinch which
perfectly complements the mischievous
humor and Bray animation of the film the
live-action version had its own hit song
where are you Christmas an original
track that was co-written by Mariah
Carey little Taylor Momsen sings a sweet
rendition of the song as Cindy Lou Who
well country superstar Faith Hill
released an official recording and music
video it peaked at number 26 on the US
Billboard country charts
and has no doubt been belted in showers
for years after the movie's release the
first film though offered a truly iconic
and unique addition to holiday music
with the original version of you're a
mean one mr. Grinch mr. Grinch it was
sung by booming bass vocalists Thurl
Ravenscroft and has since been covered
by tons of folks including Jim Carrey as
the Grinch and even the cast of Glee
finally let's look at what audience and
critics have to say there's no
Metacritic score for the original
because it was released so long ago
audiences though gave it an 8 point 4
out of 10 but let's take that with the
grain of salt
these reviews poured in way after the
release so surely a bit of nostalgia is
at play here the 2000 jump carry version
has a 6 point 1 out of 10 from audiences
and only a 45% on Metacritic ouch this
year's version only fared slightly
better with a 6 point 3 audience score
out of 10 and a 53% critics score so
which one is the best I'd say this
year's version because it feels like a
fully modern update on the Yuletide
classic the newest take on the film
feels truly different and not just
because it's the first 3d animated
Grinch movie we get a new perspective on
everyone's favorite green Grouch as
illumination gives him a charming new
look and a deeper origin story at the
end even with all its departures from
earlier versions of the Grinch the movie
stays rooted and Seuss's basic message
about empathy and redemption through
community
[Music]